Hey everyone! We have done compounding and we have done discounting but we need to take it a step further because we need to know if projects are propped overtime that is our week I'll bring the opportunity cost of the capital that we are clearing overtime with the income stream that that capital is going to bring that is if the investment is to be economic profits we have to look at income stream over the number of time. That we are considering to do this we are going to use what's called Net Present Value and Net Present Value is going to be looking at out income changes over time with the various discount rates in those years so to set this up.
Our Net Present Value is going to look something like this we're going to have our income stream I'm going to call this.
I am going to have our standard discount formula one plus are in your one so this is the income streaming your one then we're going to add in the income stream in year 2/1 + r and that's going to be in the second year then we're going to go to the third year.
And this is 1 / r11i / 1 + r and this is the third year and so on and so forth about ever many time. We are looking at now.
What do a simple example just to make this concrete let's say that you are investing in your company and you were able to acquire $150,000 in capital expenses that you need for your investment the people who you are working with are okay.
For this to go 3 years so we're going to be looking at a time of 3 and you tell them at a 6% discount rates or equals 6% these are the numbers that you are expecting over the three years that we actually do the discount the discounting later but we're going to go ahead and put in the income streams for the given years in year one you expect the investment to yield $50,000.
R2 you expect the investment to yield $75,000 and in year 3 you expect the investment to yield $80,000 so old how old is in the three years that $150,000 investment is going to yield $205,000 now that all looks good what if you took this 75,000 this 80,000 in this 50,000 and you discounted it by the years because then you can take that money.
And make more money off of it or is this actually in an economically profitable.
So to do this to figure this out what we're going to do is set our formula here.
And this was 50,000 over our discount rate was 6%.
I need actually right 6% not 60%.
Over 66% now I'm saying it backwards and then 75000 / 1 + 0.06 and our second year and then lastly we had $80,000.
1 + 0.06 in our third year and when we sold this down these are the individual numbers that we get 47169 and 81 cents and then we have 66749 and 73 cents.
And our last number is $67169.54.
so the present value the net present value of this future stream of income is going to toad.
181000 + $89.10 so what we do see is that after discounting for the various years with this income stream even accounting for that $150,000 that we borrow to have on this income from we still earn $31,089.10 so this is an economically profitable investment and so we should pursue this particular activity if this number has been less than the $150,000 investment we would not want to pursue this.
And I can show you what that looks like if we account for your is that ugly word again.
Inflation let's say that over the course of three years.
We had 5% inflation so what we're really seeing is this 6% interest rate.
Discount rate that we have here is going to be bumped up by another 5%.
And what's going to take place is this $181,000 is not worth as much as what it would have been worth.
So what's assume that when we go to get this long we get tags and additional 5% on top of the actual true cost of borrowing a 6% per year so now what we see is our net present value is equal to in going to have our seen income streams as before so 50,000.
And that's going to be over 1 + 0.11.
And then I'm going to have 75000.
Again when use the same discounting rates here and then we have the 80,000 as our last income stream and this gives us your .01 1/4 raised to the now when we do this this is going to now give us.
45000.
And for $45.05.
$60,000 871.68 and then lastly $58,495.31 and when we add all of those together we get $164,000 412 so yet we're still profitable $150,000 investment but we are not as profitable as before so we do want to make sure that we are keeping track of what inflation is doing to do our income streams because it does erode the purchasing power of the dollar. Alright that is its hope you have enjoyed.